the head of the world health
organization has declared the fast
spreading monkey pox outbreak a global
health emergency cases have been
detected in more than 70 countries the
health agency hopes to the declaration
will draw more attention and resources
to fighting the disease here's what the
head of the who had to say
so in short
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly
through new models of transmission
about which we understand too little and
which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
for all of these reasons
i have decided that the global monkey
box outbreak represents
a public health emergency of
international concern
let's get more right now from kai cooper
schmidt he's a science journalist with a
background in molecular biomedicine
so first of all the significance of the
world health organizations declaration
tell us more about that
well you know declaring a public health
emergency of international concern is
the loudest alarm bell the w jo can ring
the hope of course is that this creates
the awareness that this spurs countries
into action
whether that actually happens is another
question remember the last time the who
declared the phdic was in january 2020
for covet 19 and i didn't get the sense
at the time that that really spurred a
lot of countries interaction but but
that is the hope
now the who's head tedious
uh
made the decision without the full
backing of the emergency committee what
is behind that disagreement
yes that is actually unprecedented so
the the pagic this tool was created in
2005 with the with the international
health regulations and
normally the director general has always
followed their advice in this case the
committee was split so a small majority
of members actually was against
declaring a public health emergency of
international concern and you know
they've given different reasons for why
that might be so you know one argument
was that this is not spreading in the
general population at the moment it's
concentrated in men who have sex with
men it hasn't caused a lot of deaths so
far
but but in the end there was a lot of
pressure from epidemiologists and almost
all the experts i talked to
were you know convinced that this would
help uh curb the outbreak and so i think
there was a lot of pressure on him to to
to go this way but it is unusual
and and experts like the ones you note
do seem to be taken by surprise by the
pace
of this virus the amount that it's
spreading how concerned should people be
yes i mean what is unusual about this
outbreak is really that it is affecting
one particular group at the moment when
we have sex with men and that it is
spreading at a pace that we haven't
really seen with monkeypox in the past
this is not a virus that actually
transmits all that well
um so at the moment we think that the
sexual networks that exist make it much
easier for this virus to spread from
person to person these are just much
more densely connected networks than
than are usually affected
and but that also means that the risk is
very different for different groups at
the moment so at the moment at the
moment the the risk communication has to
be that anybody who is a man having sex
with men um you know needs to be
particularly careful it's at a much
higher risk than than the rest of the
population but of course over time this
virus can spill over into other groups
we don't know whether it can find other
densely connected networks that it can
spread in and so you know the wjo hopes
to curb this outbreak before it does
that
science journalist kaikou for schmidt
there with the latest on that health
emergency thank you very much
pleasure
you